- [Instructor] What I would like you to do
is pause this video and
see if you can calculate
each of these percentages, and
ideally do it in your head.
All right, now let's do it together.
Now I said, how are you
going to do it in your head?
You might be tempted to write down these
as multiplication problems
and have to write it down.
And that might be a reasonable thing,
but these are particular percentages
that you might see a lot of in life
and so it's useful to think
about them in your head.
For example, 1%.
1% is the same thing as 1 over 100.
So 1% of 900 is the same thing
as 1/100 of 900.
And so this question boils down to really
what is 900 divided by 100.
And that of course is equal to 9.
Let's do another example.
What's 10% of 630?
Well 10%
is equal to 10 over 100,
which is the same thing as 1 over 10.
So if I were to say 10% of 630,
that's the same thing
as saying 1/10 of 630.
So this all boils down
to 630 divided by 10,
which you would recognize as 63.
All right, let's do this
next one, 20% of 45.
You might recognize already,
and if you haven't already,
it's good to recognize that 20%
is the same thing as 20 over 100,
or that it's the same thing as 1 over 5.
It's good to just know
that hey, 20% is 1/5.
So if I'm saying 1/5 of 45,
that's the same thing as 45 divided by 5,
which is of course, equal to 9.
Let's keep going. This is too much fun.
25%, you might recognize
that's the same thing as 1/4,
25% is 25 over 100.
If you divide the numerator
and the denominator by 25,
you're going to get 1 over 4.
So this is equivalent to
saying what's 1/4 of 28.
Well, 28 divided by 4 is, of course, 7.
Let's keep going. 50% of 128.
You might recognize 50%
is the same thing as 1/2.
It's 50 over 100, which is equal to 1/2.
And so we're really just
saying what's half of 128,
or what's 128 divided by 2.
And that of course would be 64.
And then last but not least, 400% of 8.
Well, 400%, that's the
same thing as 400 over 100,
or it's equal to 4.
So that's really saying what's 4 times 8.
So 4 times 8 is, of course, equal to 32.
And we are done.